[Music]
he had not been aware of that he
literally literally had not been aware
of what had transpired what happened
yes i was um doing a lot of grace
i was under the impression of things
that happened
now what's important is precisely to be
sure that such a situation
will not be possible for our future
well it was a major diplomatic blunder
uh the u.s
not telling france of an end to a
submarine deal a big one uh dealing
instead with australia and the french
were really upset about it so much so
they pulled the ambassador from the u.s
the u.s the french ambassador to the u.s
out now the president said it was a
clumsy mistake didn't apologize but
that's the first part of his europe trip
we'll start there with our panel ben
dominic publisher of the federalist
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina
trey clumsy and he didn't even know
about it is what he told the french
president macron
yeah i'm not sure i would have admitted
that even if it were true
i can tell you imagine how bad your life
is when you are
happier meeting with the president of
france who you stiffed in a submarine
deal you'd rather do that than go meet
with the progressive caucus in the house
how bad is your life if you prefer that
yeah so
let's turn there harold i mean we saw
what happened last night up on capitol
hill the punt
to next week there's still some thought
that it might be two weeks some people
are saying sometime before thanksgiving
where this all gets ironed out i mean
it's it's pretty ugly it may still
happen but it's pretty ugly
thanks for having me on and i would
agree with you it's not the way i'm sure
he orchestrated or choreographed it but
sometimes big time legislation is not
choreographed it was not choreographable
in the way you may like
at the end of the day if they get this
pass 1.75 trillion you have a 1.2 1.25
trillion dollar
package for infrastructure that's three
trillion dollars he would have gotten in
the first year in in the presidency
again to your point it has not been
pretty but i give credit to to some of
the a lot of the progressives because
they kept their word and i think now the
question is whether or not
uh senators mansion and cinema can keep
their word as well and if they do we
will pass an historic piece of
legislation again not pretty the way
they did it but we often don't see this
kind of sausage making we just happen to
be seeing it in this instance
talk about not pretty ben this story
that was from the wall street journal
and now is moving forward about the
possible plans to pay illegal immigrants
who've been separated by their in their
families some 450 000
or more representative dan crenshaw
tweeting out biden wants to pay illegal
immigrants 450 000 for their hardship
while breaking our laws for perspective
if a service member is killed in action
their next of kin gets an insurance
payment of 400 thousand dollars let that
sink in i'm not sure
i believed this story when i first read
it ben um
but but there hasn't been pushback yet
and we haven't got an official um shoot
down of this story
you know brett i'm as the publisher of
the federalists people pitch me
occasionally stories and when this one
came into my email i reacted by assuming
that it was not true i could not believe
that something like this was actually
happening and yet we are seeing uh that
there is not push back to this that this
is something that is that is ongoing and
the amount of backlash that i think
you're going to see to this
is is just going to be unprecedented
people are not going to accept this uh
and just go along with it and just to
circle back to harold's point
i don't think that this dog's breakfast
of of a bill or or fire festival dinner
if you want the more current uh
recollection is going to be something
that you can actually sell to the
american people the biden administration
seems to be going down this road of
meandering through all of these
different topics that are of the utmost
importance to the american people and
then just sort of saying trust us what
your what we're doing is going to be
something that you like when they have
no major thing no major thing to point
to that's actually going to make a
difference and certainly the fact that
they couldn't get this done in time for
the virginia election is something that
weighs on the minds of a lot of dc
democrats tonight
well and particularly terry mcauliffe in
the virginia election and uh speaking of
which uh final days before tuesday's
election day we saw the poll that we had
last night a big shift in that race now
you've got a lot of different things
happening the younkin communications
director uh saying that terry
mcauliffe's campaign has been the
dirtiest nastiest most dishonest
campaign uh in virginia history this
morning they're closing out his career
by going even lower there was this
moment this morning where uh there were
these guys with tiki torches trey uh in
front of a young bus saying we're all in
for glenn uh suggesting you know
harkening back to charlottesville uh and
and the nazis and and the white
supremacists who march in that uh in
that march
late today there was a lot of
allegations that they were democrats
actually the lincoln project said that
they are taking credit or
uh
saying that they were behind it
the yunkan people are saying they think
they're democrats bottom line you've got
a lot of stuff going on then you look at
this this is a
a flyer that came out in which uh you
would think that it's yunkan just being
endorsed by donald trump and that's a
republican thing and trump next to
younken and thumbs up but if you look
closely on the back of this flyer it's
the democratic party of virginia and
specifically
the mcauliffe campaign
that really wants that tie between
donald trump and glenn younkin
yeah i mean brett if if people say that
it was it was democrats in the lincoln
project they're both right i mean the
lincoln project is a bunch of democrats
so
i
i
this is why people hate politics i mean
there may be reasons to not vote for
glenn younkin but he's not a white
supremacist so
the fact that democrats
are on the verge of losing in virginia
for what the first time in 20 years
uh
when you run a candidate who's been
around since the hamilton burdell and
he's a clinton acolyte that no one's
excited about uh they found virginia
democrats found a way to make that state
competitive
i'll give you last word harold we're
going to do without winners and losers
but you got the last word here
if glenn younkin who's i think run a
great campaign so far who reminds me a
little bit of trey gowdy and some of the
republicans that i served with whom i
respected so greatly if he decides to
bring in a guy which i think he's going
to bring in donald trump in the last few
days who lost that state by 10 points
maybe he doesn't have it locked up yet
this campaign has not been the prettiest
campaign
but we'll have an outcome tuesday and i
agree it will pretend what will happen
nick in next year's midterms but i
wouldn't count terry mcauliffe out and i
certainly for glenn young can bring
donald trump in it leads me to believe
he doesn't have this locked up yet
all right ben i owe you next time thank
you panel have a great weekend hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else